montréal hochelaga maisonneuve centre
sud ville marie au petit matin un enfant
marche sur le trottoir
il marche vers son école ce matin sa
maman l'a embrassée
je te souhaite une belle journée monty
nez dans son sac d'écolier
il transporte un véritable trésor des
crayons de toutes les couleurs les
cahiers pour écrire des livres
d'histoires des histoires à lire
ah oui et une collation
le gros sac au dos la confiance au coeur
cet enfant marche vers son école il
marche vers son bonheur à deux coins de
rue
une autre enfant qui marchent aussi vers
son école mais élevé seule
ce matin en silence un regard au
comptoir de la cuisine est pas de petit
déjeuner en silence
elle s'établit un pantalon un chandail
les couleurs sont délavées les vêtements
sont élimé mais que voulez-vous à cheval
donné la bride ni jamais vraiment
regardé elle est partie sans faire de
bruit son papa est encore au lit il a
travaillé fort toute la nuit
c'est vrai et pour trois fois rien alors
dans son sac à elle c'est la même chose
trois fois rien
son petit sac au dos sa grande faim au
ventre
cet enfant marche aussi personnes écoles
aubin la regardez moi ça à regarder ça
là bas c'est la chamaille quatre enfants
daisy bouriffé les cheveux en bataille
c'est clair qu'ils viennent d'ailleurs
leur peau leur peau et pas de la même
couleur aux belges qui est vrai que
c'est des réfugiés je vous dis qu'on est
même à la manche et c'est vrai ils
viennent d'ailleurs et d'ailleurs ils
viennent d'arriver
leur papa et leur maman ne savent pas ni
la langue ni le travail ni le canada
mais ils savent la souffrance et la
guerre mais voilà voilà quatre enfants
tout seul au pays de l'hiver leurs
familles et sans le sou sans feuilles
sans portefeuille
ils sont quatre frères et soeurs et se
tiennent par la main et il court il
court vers leur école
le sac à dos ce sera pour demain
voilà toute une ribambelle qui n'a pas
encore dix ans et tout ce petit monde
qui convergent vers la même école et non
pas encore dix ans que déjà la ville et
ses parts
le premier est prêt à apprendre la
seconde à la faim au ventre et les
autres son droit sortis de l'aérogare
alors le premier il sera président et
les autres indigent
c'est ça la vie la chienne de vie
et pourtant pourtant tous ces enfants le
soir venu lorsqu'il ferme leurs yeux et
font exactement le même rêve
il rêve d'être heureux il ne le formule
pas ainsi mais il rêve d'une vie
accomplie que leur talent soit mise à
profit
est-ce trop demander est-ce trop nous
demander ces enfants nous demande un
pont un pont vers leur avenir n'est ce
pas notre responsabilité collective que
de le construire
c'est difficile il est vrai mais si le
secret consistait à nous unir nous nous
les grains de partout s'il suffisait
qu'on abatte nos silos nos silos
d'adultes un peu idiot new frontier nos
barrières tout ce qui sépare nos man 2
le monde scolaire le monde communautaire
le monde des affaires
s'il suffisait qu'on regroupe qu'on
regroupe tous nos talents nos forces nos
idées nos deniers à un jet de pierre du
pont jacques-cartier une belle vieille
école avec une aile peu délabré qu'à
cela ne tienne on va la rénover ou ça
prend 10 où beaucoup de choses
qu'à cela ne tienne on va les trouver
une compagnie qui vend d'énergie frappe
à la porte d'une belle grosse banque
et puis de pelé de compagnie a mis
ensemble s investissent et
s'investissent la cour de récré on voit
la retaper le barbelé on vole l'arraché
l'asphalt envol l'enlever on va la
remplacer par des tapis de jeu coloré on
va semer un potager bio et on va planter
des arbres des arbres matures pour que
des sous les enfants puissent venir s'y
reposer sur ça prend des ateliers vous
dites un laboratoire
quelle bonne idée et une cuisine et un
studio de radio et un studio de télé une
bibliothèque
ça s'entend un gymnase pour pouvoir
s'entraîner une scène
une scène pour apprendre à s'exprimer
et pourquoi pas sur le toit de l'école
pourquoi pas une terrasse pour que les
enfants puissent aussi venir étudier
même si c'est l'été ces enfants sont
venus ces enfants viendront il y aura
des professeurs des professeurs
extraordinaires qui vont redoubler
d'ardeur parce qu'il leur faudra bien il
leur faudra bien quitter leur école avec
leur classe pour venir jusqu'à la ruelle
mais ils n'ont pas peur il plonge
ils innovent ils redoublent d'ardeur
ça fait longtemps ses professeurs ils ne
comptent plus leurs heures
et puis les organismes du quartier les
gens des hommes et des femmes absolument
formidable et dévoué des passionnés du
monde intelligents qui savent que pour
aider les enfants il faut il faut aussi
aider les parents tout ce beau monde
adulte tous horizons confondus
des passionnés et puis arrivèrent les
enfants
des enfants merveilleux ne sont ils pas
au merveilleux
ils nous viennent de partout de plus de
50 écoles ils sont mille quatre cent par
année à fréquenter une ruelle dans deux
quartiers soixante dix communautés
culturelles
c'est l'onu la ruelle c'est l'onu des
enfants des professeurs des bénévoles on
peut les compter
comme à l'école mais pour tout vous dire
on ne compte plus on ne compte plus le
sourire
on ne compte plus la joie de grandir on
ne mesure plus la fierté et la fierté de
ses enfants réussir de l'aide aux
devoirs des cinémas des courts métrages
des ateliers de cuisine de jardinage de
science de botanique de robotique à
ventre affamé
tous ces merdes tout au tout ventre
affamé n'a pas d'oreille mais levante le
ventre apaisé et tous tous ces
merveilles laruelle a maintenant 7 ans
les enfants ont grandi
les enfants ont déjoué les statistiques
estime de soi lecture mathématiques on
le sait c'est très très mesuré les
enfants à l'école sont restés accrochés
dans un quartier qu'on disait
défavorisés se cacher au fond un monde
un monde de possibilités et dix enfants
qui hier avait froid et avait faim
seront demain cinéaste ingénieurs et
médecins
c'est la petite histoire de notre grand
espoir au départ ce n'était qu'une
ruelle dans une ville qui en compte 1000
ce n'est qu'une ville dans un monde qui
en compte 100 milles ce ne sont que que
14 cents enfants dans un monde qui en
compte des milliards mais si dans tous
les quartiers du monde s'unissent les
grandes partout pour réunir des enfants
que tout sépare à la fin ce sont les
ruelles de tous les pays qui vont
converger et ce
on les rêves des enfants du monde qui
vont se réaliser
montréal hochelaga maisonneuve
centre-sud ville marie